avec quelqu'un d'extrême droite qui est
contre l'islam et les musulmans je ne
comprends pas
je comprends vos confrontations et
éditoriales sur des plateaux avec lui le
débat parfait
Eric Zemmour c'est beaucoup je peux
continuer monsieur que vous soyez amis
avec quelqu'un qui pense globalement que
l'islam et les musulmans sont de trop je
ne comprends pas pourquoi je ne
comprends pas que vous soutiez monsieur
comment pouvez-vous être le soutien de
Monsieur Mélenchon qui lui aussi a été
condamné
avant d'être vraiment amis demande pour
qui la voté autrement c'est pas des amis
avec des gens et toi quand tu soutiens
un Mélenchon ou des gens qui sont c'est
pas mon avis mélange pas c'est pas mon
ami
c'est un soutien de Monsieur Mélenchon
qui lui aussi a été condamné c'est un
soutien Monsieur Mélenchon qui tient un
discours anti républicain qui frôle de
plus en plus l'appel à l'insurrection
la violence vous soutenez la violence
vous soutenez la violence vous soutenez
des gens pour qui le pouvoir
de se prend pas dans les urnes mais dans
la rue et par la violence et vous venez
me donner des cours vous êtes vous êtes
amis vous êtes un représentant
malheureusement de quelque chose que je
croyais disparu à gauche totalitaire
avec Sandrine rousse
ni moi n'avons été condamnés pour des
propos terribles
mais il me semble pardon que Cyril il le
dit souvent sur ce plateau qu'il a il a
mis avec des gens qui ont fait de la
prison de gras rien à voir bah il a été
condamné il est pas là
avec des gens c'est pourtant des amis
proches
qui ont purgé
ça veut dire que si dans tes amis si
dans tes amis un seul était condamné
pour une un jour ou n'importe quoi tu le
dégage de tes amis je n'ai pas d'amis
d'extrême droite et j'en suis fier voilà
tout ce que je dis je n'ai pas d'amis
parce que éliminer
le nouveau démo tu ramènes toute ta
liste Rousseau je te ramène tout
maintenir parce qu'avant la fin du débat
Gilles Verdez est-ce qu'avant la fin du
débat vous allez sortir un argument
valable moi c'est ma grande angoisse
pour l'instant